welcome to the heavy spoilers show I'm
your host definition aka the superfan of
HBO that's gonna put you in the HB No
yeah near work on those intros with the
west-world back for season three fans
are already working overtime and
wondering what could be going on in this
world full of splendor as with all new
seasons in the series the third entry
has a brand new opening credits scene
and it is possible that there are
messages hidden within that could tease
what exactly is going on throughout this
video we're going to be breaking down
the introduction and discussing what it
could be hinting at in the future we
will be going over some of the plot
points from the first episode so if
you're not fully up to date then I
highly recommend that you turn off now
make sure you subscribe to the channel
as we do breakdowns of Westworld every
week and please drop a thumbs up if you
enjoy the video without the way I just
want to give a huge thank you for
clicking this now let's get into a
breakdown of West world's opening
credits okay so the third season has
changed quite a bit from what we're used
to in several ways
dolorous is now out in what could be
considered the real world though it
could also be a simulation within a
simulation but I don't want to get into
that and the entire aesthetic of the
show has completely changed the credits
open much in the same way that all of
the prior entries have with what appears
to be a Sun rising in the first season
this was the Sun coming up over a human
host in the second it was the body of a
buffalo host and in this third entry
it's the body of an eagle host which
appears throughout the opening in the
first season this human host could have
ended up in several ahem positions as
two was seen getting it on and another
ended up riding on a horse firing a gun
similar to how Dolores would in the
second entry this showed the rising of
the hosts in the park and how they would
connect with one another and rebel
against their oppressors in season two
the Buffalo ended up jumping over the
edge of the science area in the park
showcasing that the entire illusion was
going to come crumbling down in the
third opener the bird flies towards a
jet engine that then transforms into the
Sun and slowly the bird melts away and
begins to fall apart this is clearly not
to Icarus the ancient Greek story in
which the aforementioned character flew
too close to the Sun
in an attempt to escape Crete Icarus and
his father created wings held together
with wax in order to get away from the
location but as we mentioned they got
too close to the Sun the wax melted and
they ended up falling to their deaths
nice
this could metaphorically show that the
hosts are flying too close to the Sun
and are getting in a very dangerous
position that will ultimately lead to
their downfall they have passed into a
world that they simply aren't equipped
to deal with and are close to falling
apart because of it birds used to be
some of the only things that could find
the planet then man built the aeroplane
and proved that human ingenuity could
match him mother nature the bird being
overtaken by the jet could show that
humans can always develop something to
take down or match the hosts should ever
come to it shortly after this we can see
a piano being strung by a mechanical arm
this has been a feature that has
appeared in all three seasons opening
credits and there are also exact repeats
of certain elements such as the host
hands that play the piano these hands
play the theme tune so it makes sense
that they would return here as they're
very much the backbone of the opening
and they provide it with that theme tune
that not even a memory wipe can get out
your head the second big element in the
opening credits scene is a host figure
approaching their reflection in a pool
initially this seems like a nod to the
painting the Creation of Adam by
Michelangelo this painting forms part of
the Sistine Chapel ceiling and it's
meant to represent God giving life to
Adam in the book of Genesis Ford already
discussed this painting in the show and
he pointed out that it took 500 years
for people to notice the shape of a
human brain behind God Deford this show
that the divine gift does not come from
a higher power but rather from our own
brains this reaching out of the host to
itself could show the fallacy of
believing in something else as all we
have for ourselves the host seems to
realize this in the credits as when it
finally touches the water it falls
through it could also be a nod to the
Greek story of narcissus you may have
heard the term narcissist before but the
word actually pulls from Greek mythology
narcissus was a hunter who was
incredibly beautiful many fell in love
with him but he ended up becoming
corrupted by this and he hated those
that obsessed over him he caused them to
kill themselves in order to prove their
love and ultimately he believed himself
to be above all others be
cuz of its looks this could mirror
Dolores and the hosts who believe
themselves to be above humans and I just
realized I'm pretty much crapping on the
house right now
don't worry Bernard I still love you
after leaving a ton of bodies behind him
someone close to one of the victims pray
to the gods to punish him for all the
pain that he had caused narcissus ended
up walking by a pool of water and after
drinking some he saw his own reflection
and ended up becoming obsessed with it
in some depictions he fell into the pool
after becoming so fixated upon his looks
and because of this he drowned in others
he killed himself because he was unable
to have the thing he desired most in the
world himself and yeah there's just a
lot of subtext going on here
similar to narcissus the hosts could end
up falling through and it is possible
that their obsession with trying to take
down the humans will be their undoing we
know that before this season Dolores
only saw the worst of humanity those
that were rich enough to be able to
afford Westworld
used it to live out their worst desires
and because of this the hosts were used
and abused
however we know from the story of Caleb
that humanity itself has its own divides
and that Dolores probably has more in
common with him than she would like to
admit caleb has a robot companion and
has clear divide between that and the
hosts showing that everything operates
in shades of grey rather than black and
white in another shot we see a Dany
lying spreading its seeds this then
transforms into the supercomputer that
we learn in the first episode
predetermined a path for every person on
the planet it shows their destiny and is
unquestioned it is likely that Dolores
and Coe will try to destroy this in the
series as she was heavily fixated upon
it in the first episode the Dani line
could represent the world and humanity
spreading their seed and thus going out
of control these seeds then becoming the
machine that puts everything back on
course
could cement that it has brought order
to everything thus destroying it would
destabilize things and finally set
humanity free the spherical shape is
repeated throughout the opening not only
in the cells were also the Sun and jet
engine it shows that the machine is tied
in with everything circles and things
being planned have popped up in the
series before most namely the maize
which was a big focus in the show early
on this was a route for William to
follow to get to the center
it's pre-planned path has many things in
common with the preordained journey that
humans are now given humans are now
stuck in their own loops their own set
of programming and the similarities are
very eerie I think the third season will
really focus on the class divide and how
the rich pretty much run everything and
people below them lead a very
subordinate type lifestyle much in
service to them the circle motif can
also be seen repeated with the host
being dipped into a liquid this is
something that has been present in the
credit scene for every season thus far
however season 3 differs in a major way
the figure in that is being dumped into
red liquid which could indeed indicate
the blood that will be spilled by the
humans mixing with them to me this shape
also has a lot of similarities to the
swastika which is to set to feature
heavily in the season from the
post-credits scene in that we see maven
war world and the circle on a red
background with a shape in the middle it
does fit a very similar aesthetic if the
season is about liberation from an
all-powerful almost dictator like figure
that decides everything for the populace
then this could also be reflected in the
storyline of Maeve could she be freeing
those in war world from their loops much
in the same way that Dolores will free
the humans trapped by the thinking's of
a machine personally I think so I love
the way that the first two seasons were
about freeing machines from the humans
and that the third season could be about
freeing humans from a machine there are
tons of things to look forward to in the
season and obviously the further we get
into it the more these titles will make
sense hopefully I've given you some
things to think about and you've enjoyed
us discussing what could or could not be
going on with the opening titles
obviously I'd love to hear your thoughts
on the credits and what you think they
hint towards in the season I'm sure
there's a whole host of things excuse
the pun so comment below and let me know
and if you enjoy this video then please
drop a thumbs up as it massively helps
us out you want something else to watch
after this then make sure you check out
our breakdown over the first episode
which is going to be linked at the end
we're gonna be going over the episodes
every week so it's definitely worth
staying locked to the channel if the
show leaves you scratching your head you
want to support us from as little as 99
cents a month then please click the join
button below
we massively appreciate it and as a
thank you you get access to content
early you want to come chat to us after
the show
either follow us at definition whitey or
click
discord link in the description below
every month we give away free movies to
people or subscribe to the channel and
this Monty can win the Star Wars
Skywalker saga box set and all you have
to do is comment on a video and make
sure you sub with notifications on the
more videos you comment on the more you
have a chance of winning so make sure
you get involved the one it's gonna be
chosen at random on the 15th of April
and the set will be shipped out from the
intro gets the prize so best of luck to
everyone who takes part this is the
channel for people who are never missing
television so if that's the kind of
thing you like you need to subscribe to
definition thanks again for taking the
time to watch this you've been the best
and I'll see you next time take care
peace
[Music]
you